[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a este programa
especial de cultura en France 24
dedicado a la gran fiesta de la
literatura latinoamericana la Feria
Internacional del Libro de Guadalajara
en México
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tras dos años de pandemia el 2022 marcó
el regreso del evento literario más
importante del continente a su formato
original empresarial y con asistencia
libre durante nueve días más de 800.000
personas recorrieron los pasillos de la
feria Editores autores y visitantes muy
diversos con muchos niños y adolescentes
la directora Marisol celebró un balance
muy positivo para esta edición
[Música]
lo que nos ha demostrado Es que la gente
quería regresar después de dos años muy
difícil es porque Tuvimos una feria
presencial pero muy limitada del año
pasado así que esta era la feria del
verdadero regreso y lo que estamos
comprobando con esta energía desbordante
en todos los rincones de la feria son
tres mil cinco actividades lo cual puede
hablar de que hay una feria para niños
una feria para jóvenes una feria para
cada miembro de la familia para cada
personalidad que viene desde las figuras
más reconocidas hasta la gente que viene
de los pueblos de Jalisco de Jalisco
pero es una feria para todos
La perilla Internacional del Libro de
Guadalajara es un lugar privilegiado
para ver a sus autores favoritos dando
charlas descubrir nuevos libros y
promover los talentos de la literatura
de hoy en día una autora se destacó este
año la mexicana Daniela tarazona es la
ganadora de uno de los premios más
importantes de la feria el premio Sor
Juana Inés de la Cruz por su novela Isla
partida Aquí está nuestra entrevista con
ella
Muchas gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros gracias Gracias a
ustedes por el espacio ustedes la gran
ganadora del premio Sor Juana Inés de la
Cruz 2022 Cómo se siente y Qué significa
este premio en particular para usted
Bueno me siento emocionadísima
emocionadísima es el primer premio que
yo recibo había recibido otros
reconocimientos como apoyos digamos no
este tipo de cosas pero es el primer
premio Y es un premio con mucho
prestigio
mi libro ahora formará parte de Pues de
un conjunto de obras de escritoras muy
importantes y eso me llena de orgullo de
satisfacción y justamente esta novela es
la partida es la historia de una mujer
que parece un trastorno neurológico y
que se desdobla y hablando de esta
historia Usted dijo que es la partida es
un testimonio y una ficción
explicar Sí claro
esta novela parte de una experiencia
personal que tiene que ver justo con una
condición neurológica Entonces yo lo que
quería era crear una historia que
tuviera relación con todo ese tema no
que abrebara mucho de la parte real
autobiográfica Pero bueno la novela como
como bien dices que el personaje se
desdobla Entonces está esta mujer
también es una mujer que se va a una
isla a morir por ejemplo y esta mujer
también como se nombra en la novela es
muchas otras mujeres sus ancestras otras
mujeres que ha conocido es como si ella
fuera
como multitudes como un emblema de
muchas historias no en su en su también
en cómo está contada la novela de una
segunda persona una tercera como del
viaje de esto y a recibir este premio
usted habló de posicionarse en contra de
una sociedad tu uniforme
usted tiene un discurso sobre las
emociones y el reconocimiento de estas
instituciones es tan importante bueno la
protagonista la novela por ejemplo hay
una parte que tiene que ver esa también
con mi con mi vida real digamos
una de las cosas más amenazantes que yo
sentía con este trastorno era una
sensación muy fuerte Como de sentir que
estamos amenazados como por poderes
fácticos como las redes sociales el uso
de nuestros datos personales en el
internet El que nos manden publicidad
predictiva todo este tipo de cosas y eso
por un lado y por otro lado el uso de
los teléfonos inteligentes por ejemplo
el uso de la tecnología en general tan
que Abusamos mucho creo Creo que ha
modificado las relaciones y el modo de
acercarnos a los otros de comprender a
los demás no entonces las emociones se
nombran este libro las emociones se
venden como productos no y me parece
algo pues muy terrorífico en un punto No
muy algo que lo que hay que detenerse a
ver qué está pasando y poder presentar
sus obras contar sus historias en un
lugar como este como la feria de
Guadalajara que es un evento tan
importante de este continente
como como uno se siente a estar presente
en esta feria la Fil bueno Yo vengo he
venido varias veces este hace ya años
que vengo y es un espacio realmente Muy
conmovedor no es un espacio donde uno
puede no solamente ver autores que
admiran no y no solamente por ejemplo
hay hay un programa que se llama
ecosdelafil que se trata justo de llevar
autores fuera de la feria preparatorias
escuelas que estuve Antier en ese
programa entonces hay un diálogo con
lectores jóvenes Es realmente un momento
en donde la literatura y la lectura
cobran como mucha potencia mucha vida
mucho intercambio no y bueno Y ahora con
este premio en esta edición Pues
imagínate pura pura emoción y felicidad
bueno Muchas gracias De nada gracias a
ustedes
[Música]
observar incesantemente la comisura de
los labios de aquel y aquella para ver
si allí queda un rastro antiguo de leche
materna desprenderse de los labios
propios para rellenarlos con sustancias
que los hagan más carnosos pidan leche
llamen a las nodrizas corran la mano que
tiembla cuando responde el teléfono
rasca el lagrimal de un ojo turbio y
dice no me interesa grabaremos todas tus
conversaciones de cerca nadie es normal
compraremos todo lo que representes tu
propia vida para usarla nadie cree en
nada ni en su piel bajo la mascarilla de
un tratamiento en el supermercado los
anaqueles están vacíos queremos más que
nos den todos los productos de la tierra
y de las fábricas que nos extiendan
universos de quesos caminos de legumbres
que nos llenen la boca la que vomitemos
luego en casa largamente hincado sobre
el excusado es del todo probable que Si
lees un libro sobre un accidente y sales
a la calle el accidente venga atrás de
ti somos demasiados que se extermina el
sentido por completo ni el albuceo puede
ser una manera de decir no resta nada
[Música]
el intercambio cultural hace parte de
los valores que la feria del libro de
Guadalajara buscaba promover por eso la
identidad de cada edición está muy
ligada con un país invitado de honor que
viene a mostrar sus artes y su
literatura y este año el tercer más
grande de los siete emiratos árabes
Unidos fue elegido a pesar de la Barrera
del idioma su delegación nos contó su
felicidad frente a la curiosidad del
público mexicano y a las ganas de los
lectores latinos de conectar con la
cultura árabe
[Música]
nos quedamos realmente asombrados de la
gran acogida que nos dispensaron Los
visitantes mexicanos apreciamos mucho su
interés por conocer mejor nuestra
cultura y la cultura árabe en general
hemos recibido muchas preguntas mucho
interés por ejemplo algunas personas me
pidieron que escribiera su nombre en
árabe
Así que esto es realmente cautivador nos
encanta
nos hace sentir muy orgullosos de
nuestra cultura y de nuestra identidad
el interés que nos prestan esos
visitantes No sonra de verdad
[Música]
estamos en el mayor encuentro en el
mundo de las letras en español pero es
también un evento abierto la riqueza de
los autores internacionales al llamado
de la feria de Guadalajara respondieron
775 escritores de 44 países
representando a 25 lenguas distintas con
esta edición ya tenía la mirada hacia la
literatura árabe del lado de los
artistas grandes voces de esta región
como el
palentinori estaban presentes pero fue
el sirio Líbano quien cautivó la
atención de Los visitantes pionero de la
poesía moderna árabe y candidato regular
al Nobel de literatura fue su primera
vez en la feria del libro de Guadalajara
y nos compartió su alegría de estar acá
[Música]
es muy importante tener ferias como esta
extraordinario
la porque es realmente un punto de
encuentro extraordinario y casi único
ahí estamos todos de todas las lenguas y
nacionalidades o civilizaciones todos en
la misma casa y eso demuestra que el
hombre puede crear un mundo de paz y
amistad dejemos Las Guerras el
capitalismo y todo eso
con veler el capitalismo
así se termina nuestro programa especial
sobre la Feria Internacional del Libro
de Guadalajara Gracias a ustedes por su
confianza y sigan con nosotros hay más
cultura en ras 24 y 24
[Aplausos]
[Música]